[Musique]
Antoine
Aoun comme vous le voyez je suis en
fauteil roulant mais vous allez voir le
handicap est une apparence parfois et
non pas une
différence là comme vous voyez j'ai
grandi je suis né au Liban où j'ai grand
dit en bonne santé en pleine forme
jusqu'au jour où la guerre a éclaté à
l'âge de 18 ans j'ai pris une balle une
balle qui m'a touché grave j'ai une
hémorragie interne j'ai traîné longtemps
par terre on narrivait pas à me dégager
et puis j'aurais dû y passer et pourtant
je suis encore là 35 ans après
euh je vis en pleine forme oui en pleine
forme je dis même que des fois je suis
debout mais ça c'est là-haut que ça se
passe et bien cette balle au moment où
elle m'a touché elle m'a pas simplement
paralysé mes jambes elle m'a enlevé mon
rêve de gosse mon rêve tous mes rêves de
jeunes mon rêve de pilote notamment elle
m'a enlever tout ce que je pouvais
espérer dans ma vie
d'après mais et j'ai même pensé à
suicider quelque part parce que je ne
pouvais pas supporter de vivre avec cet
handicap alors 35 ans après je suis
toujours là et je peux vous dire que
tous les jours je mesure la chance
d'avoir choisi de vivre et de ne pas
passer à un autre acte donc ce qui va
suivre je vais vous raconter comment je
suis passé d'un jeune de 18 ans qui
croyait que sa vie était arrêtée que
tous ses rêves étaient suspendus à un
jeune de 53 ans qui continue à vivre qui
donne sens à sa vie et qui l'amène comme
il veut parce que il a compris dès le
départ que c'est à lui d'être maître de
son fauteuil et de ne pas laisser le
fauteuil le gérer là où il a envie
d'aller et bien j'ai grandi dans une
culture montagnarde à la base mais en
ville c'est-à-dire ce mélange de
montagne de citad j'ai grandi dans une
famille modeste dans la Bonlieu de
Beyrouth en 1975 la guerre a éclaté je
n'avais que 14 ans un an après je me
suis engagé ça a été l'engagement
l'entraînement l'éloignement de la
famille cette éducation chrétienne basé
sur l'amour et le partage a viré de bord
et de l'agneau que j'étais j'ai cherché
à me transformer en loup 1979 3 ans
après mon engagement 18 ans et bien j'ai
pris une balle elle m'a paralysé les
jambes embarqué à l'hôpital pendant 3
semaines après on m'a ammené dans un
centre de rééducation j'arrive dans le
centre de rééducation à tel point je
j'étais en voiture j'ai même pas voulu
qu'on me trans qu'on me transporte en
ambulance on rentre dans la cour et là
mon cauchemar commence et qu'est-ce que
je vois des dizaines de personnes
handicapées de tout genre je dis mais
mon dieu mais où suis-je suis-je dans
dans encore sur la planète Terre ou
ailleurs et bien qu'est-ce qui se passe
c'est là que je me suis rendu compte que
finalement j'étais handicapé et bien
l'isolement total une bulle s'est formée
autour de moi j'ai même créé un
labyrinthe de toutes pièces là j'ai
plongé dans la tristesse dans la
négativité je n'ai pas accepté le
handicap je n'ai pas accepté cette
carcasse roulante dans laquelle on m'a
installé je ne voulais qu'une chose
c'est
remarcher mais comment remarcher des
médecins avant de quitter l'hôpital ils
m'ont dit oh tu es jeune tu es en pleine
forme t'inquiète pas tu vas remarcher
mais de mois après dans ce centre de
rédu il avait la rééducation mais rien
ne bougeit tout était
pareil et c'est là c'est là que j'ai
compris que finalement ma vie a basculé
j'ai pris la pleine conscience que
j'étais devenu
handicapé
alors quoi
faire c'est là que j'ai une fois pour
toutes abandonner les armes à feu et là
on me demande d'acquérir d'autres armes
qu'on appelle les armes de la vie il
s'appelle motivation travail courage
audace désir discipline
détermination travail sourire
patience mais comment imaginez-vous à
l'âge à la fleur de l'âge à 18 ans déjà
blessé de guerre et handicapé en
plus
alors moi je me suis battu pour rester
en vie quand j'étais blessé et bien
puisque j'ai choisi de vivre et bien je
sors j'ai accepté de sortir de ce centre
de rééducation mais comment gérer le
regard le regard de ceux qui hier de du
haut de mes 1 M80 je regardais droit
dans les yeux et aujourd'hui raptissz
dans cette carcasse roulante je suis
obligé de lever la tête pour les
regarder sentiment d'infériorité que
faire et pour les entendre me dire quoi
ah mon pauvre Antoine tu as 18 ans ah
mon pauvre Antoine ta vie est fichue ah
mon pauvre Antoine quelle femme encore
voudrait vivre avec un handicapé et
certains allent même encore plus loin tu
sais Antoine je t'adore je t'aime
beaucoup mais à ta place je me colle une
balle sauf qu'ils étaient pas ma
et
bien calme dans mon labyrinthe j'ai
réfléchi je me suis dit voilà tu es face
à deux choix premier choix tu restes
dans ce centre de rééducation à
t'apitoyer à pleurer tous les jour sur
ton sort jusqu'à la fin de tes jours
deuxième choix tu t'es battu pour vivre
et bien tu acceptes de vivre et tu
trouves la sortie de ce labyrinthe pour
aller dehors pour affronter la
vie c'est sûr le deuxième choix n'est
pas du tout facile mais j'avais
éventuellement un troisième choix c'est
écouter le conseil de ceux qui me
disaient à ta place je me colle une
balle mais ça il a viré de bord tout de
suite parce que j'ai choisi de
vivre alors faut savoir que il y a deux
chances qui sont présentées à moi la
première c'est qu'une main s'est tendue
la deuxième et je le dis avec modestie
c'est que j'ai eu l'intelligence de
tendre ma main pour la
saisir on parle souvent des besoins
fondamentaux physiques boire et manger
respirer et dormir pour pouvoir exister
en tant qu'humain mais surtout ne pas
oublier les besoins fondamentaux
intellectuels s'exprimer comprendre et
être compris moi j'ai été compris donc
j'ai été reconnu mon mon entourage a
était formidable cette reconnaissance
qui m'a accordé j'avais des des amis
formidable fantastique j'avais des
parents adorables ils n'ont pas manqué à
leur devoir jamais ils se montraent
tristes devant moi
et puis cette autonomie au départ on m'a
dit que tu vas remarcher rapidement et
bien ben oui puisque je veux remarcher
j'ai mis le paquet sur la sur la
réducation imaginez-vous blessé en juin
en octobre j'étais de retour à l'école
après 3 ans de guerre où l'école était
devenue au 10e plan pour moi et bien
retour à l'école j'ai récupéré cette
autonomie je pouvais avancer j'avais
beaucoup de personnes autour de moi pour
m'aider à avancer mais si mon envie
d'avancer et mon courage et l'envie de
travailler n'était pas là j'is rien fait
dans ma vie et puis vous avez l'amour
méfiez-vous c'est dangereux parce que en
83 4 ans après ma blessure et bien je
suis arrivé en France pour retrouver
l'infirmière qui s'occupait de moi sur
mon lit d'hôpital à Beyrouth et de cette
union il y a une jolie fleur qui est né
d'ailleurs elle est dans la salle je
suis ravi et bien je suis arrivé en
France après avoir obtenu un BTS de
gestion et contat alors j'ai cherché
pour travailler et j'ai trouvé qu'un non
emploi de comptable dans une tour à la
Défense à Paris et je me suis rendu
compte très vite que c'était pas du tout
ma tasse de thé moi je voulais bouger je
voulais m'exprimer je voulais m'éclater
avec mon fauteuil je voulais que ça
bouge que que je ne sais pas que si j'ai
envie de faire un demitour comme ça
aller danser en pleine rendez-vous de
boulot pourquoi pas et bien j'avais
envie d'être là de de communiquer mais
le l'emploi de comptable et bien c'était
pas ça alors j'ai cherché pour être
commercial mais à l'époque être
handicapé et commercial au pays des
droits de l'homme c'était mission
impossible figurez-vous que ça n'a pas
beaucoup changé depuis alors j'ai
cherché et j'ai trouvé des solutions
alors j'ai fini par créer mon entreprise
dans la communication par l'objet pour
être mon propre commercial je faisais
tout dans l'entreprise sauf la
comptabilité je la
sraité alors quand je suis arrivé en
France je me suis engagé avec les scout
de France et un an après en 84 on a mis
au point un temp qui ressemble à aucun
autre là c'est dans le dans le Massif
central au montlooser on a fait 700 km
au montlooser dans le Massif Central et
bien quand j'ai vu que cette opération
elle a super bien réussi c'est là que
j'ai compris que le sport et l'aventure
coule dans mes veines et là à partir de
là les projets ils sont enchaîné et bien
87 Tour de France en tandem 89 relié
quand à Montpellier en fauteuil roulant
après 90 traversé des US 92 quand le Cap
Nord 97 euh
Beyrouth en 2000 le tour de
l'Europe par
contre bike et puis en 2009 le tour de
l'Australie
mais là vous voyez je suis en
pirogue jamais dans le plus profond de
mes rêves jamais j'aurais pensé que je
pourrais faire un projet sur l'eau
j'étais en admiration devant tous ceux
qui traversaient l'Atlantique àar machin
tout ça et puis moi un beau jour un de
mes potes d'ailleurs vous allez voir
Philippe qui passe après moi que
j'appelle mes deux potes c'est des tarés
comme moi en quelque sorte qui aiment
bien l'aventure qui sont des coureurs de
l'extrême et bien ils me disent Antoine
on aimerait bien faire quelque chose
avec toi mais quoi et puis un beau jour
ils m'appelle ils me disent viens dîner
ok bon on a trouvé on va traverser la
Méditerranée en
pirrogue ben les gars écoutez moi j'ai
pas du tout le pied marin il ditent
t'inquiète pas nous non plus pour me
défiler encore plus j'ai dit ben vous
savez je connais rien au courant marin
te tracasses pas nous non plus j'ai dit
ils m'ont eu les cons allez hop
ok on jeetend la main et puis on y va ça
c'était en septembre 2011 on a fait
notre projet fin juillet et 1er août
2012 pendant 10 mois 11 mois
entraînement à bloc 2011 2012 ça a été
un hiver archi rude en France en
Normandie là où j'habite à quand on a eu
des températures jusqu'à - 17-20 mais
jamais nous nous sommes défilés devant
l'entraînement tous les weekends on
était en entraînement toutes les
semaines on s'entraînait on a appris à
gérer cette pode parce que figurez-vous
que cette bête on croit qu'elle part
droit mais non elle tourne sur elle-même
il faut apprendre à la gérer et puis on
a appris à gérer les vagues comment
comment sait moi dans le plus profond de
mes croyances j'étais persuadé que moi
le Libanais d'origine tombé dans la
Manche en plein hiver mon cur mon cœur
s'arrête net et ben figurez-vous qu'on
est tombé plus d'une fois et mon cœur
fonctionne encore ça veut dire que on
s'arrête par rapport à des croyances et
on se limite avec des habitudes et avec
des des des zones de confort ça ce
projet 250 km en nonstop en 40 en 39h et
42 minutes et euh nous sommes toujours
là en 2013 et un autre forme une autre
forme de défi j'ai écrit un livre Ma vie
en 3D désir discipline
détermination en 2007 j'ai décidé de
vendre mon entreprise et quand j'ai
décidé de vendre mon entreprise c'est là
que je me suis formé au technique de
coaching PNL neagram loi d'attraction et
aujourd'hui j'exerce comme coach et
conférencier
comment imaginer au fond de mon
labyrinthe moi qui pleurais mon rêve de
pilote qu'un jour je pourrais piloter
moi-même si je m'étais arrêté à me dire
voilà et bien ma vie est fichue allez
Antoine mets terme à ta vie parce que
jamais tu seras pilote jamais tu feras
ceci jamais tu feras cela jamais tu
pourras draguer ou jamais tu pourras
séduire encore ça vous fait peut-être
rire mais ça n'a jamais été dans mes
convictions d'intégrer un ordre
quelconque et puis là je peux piloter je
suis pas le seul d'ailleurs il y a plein
d'autres personnes handicapées qui
pilotent et
puis si j'avais passé à l'acte si
j'avais agi pour arrêter ma
vie j'aurais pas créé mon entreprise
j'aurais pas fondé ma famille j'aurais
pas vu mes enfants grandir j'aurais pas
eu le plaisir de voir même si vous êtes
dans le noir vos jolis sourires en face
et
bien je n'aurais pas non
plus
sautez en
[Musique]
parachute
alors nous avons tous des rêves des
rêves
d'enfance qui n' a pas on en a tous et
on aimerait bien tous les réaliser mais
il y a des rêves qui sont réalisables et
d'autres pas mais à partir du moment où
un rêve peut-être
réalisé on le transforme en objectif à
partir du moment où le désir est là s'il
y a le désir et bien l'objectif se
dessine mais pour pouvoir voir
l'objectif et pouvoir l'atteindre il
faut un plan d'action
c'est-à-dire la discipline en quelque
sorte c'est la méthode et puis la
détermination c'est isoler les peurs
c'est ne plus écouter ceux qui viennent
vous dire oh là là mon pauvre Antoine
qu'est-ce que tu vas faire traverser la
Méditerranée mais la Méditerranée elle
se déchaîne d'un coup qu'est-ce que tu
veux la vie est cher Antoine réfléchis
ben ça vous l'isolez vous fabriquez
votre projet et moi tant que je suis
dans cette méthode le fait que je
m'entraîne le fait que je respecte ce
plan d'action et le fait que je me dis
je sais où je veux aller mon objectif il
reste visible devant moi et je peux
l'atteindre aujourd'hui
coach et conférencier je bourlingue un
peu partout des fois on m'appelle on me
dit est-ce que vous venez dans le sud je
dis vous savez ma limite géographique
c'est c'est l'univers et oui parce que
j'ai envie d'aller partout j'ai envie de
bouger j'ai envie de pouvoir faire des
choses pourquoi parce que le désir il
est là à partir du moment où le désir il
est là et bien je sais que la méthode le
plan d'action je le construis et je peux
aller vers la réalisation de mon
objectif qui reste toujours
visible alors n'oubliez pas une chose il
n'y a que ceux qui se fixent pas
d'objectifs qui les atteignent jamais
merci pour votre
[Musique]
attention